dave de maras he said I work in the
office project group instead of the
applaud our artificial intelligence and
research group long stories to how I got
here for this tutorial I'd be happy to
share off-camera over a beer sometime
using CNG Ches Python interface for deep
learning is the title of our tutorial
CNT K is Microsoft's cognitive toolkit
they call it it used to stand for I
believe computational Network toolkit
but the names have changed but the theme
is still the same
the idea is to support these neural nets
with multiple hidden layers for machine
learning problems if you want a copy of
the slides you can go to this address
cross-entropy net slash PI data if you
want to copy the notebooks they are also
at the same address all right in a
little bit of humor or what dropout
called a deep learning hype instead of
back propaganda humorous take from ml
hipster and Naomi Safra topics to be
covered during the tutorial things that
I said I would cover cognitive toolkit
installation just to make sure you have
an example that you've seen and it's
been recorded and you can go over what
went wrong here in case in case things
go wrong you know let's Microsoft
generally speaking installation goes
pretty well but you never know why would
you laugh at that what is machine
learning we'll do a simple gradient
descent example don't stress too much
about the math I'm just trying to expose
you to things actually this concepts to
underlie this deep learning technology
are actually extraordinarily simple
there's a lot of variants on them but
sometimes you get people using different
notations for the same stuff what is
learning representations this is the
core of deep learning we'll have an
example of that
why do you graphics processing units
help we're not going to do this too much
other than we're going to use graphics
processing and talk a little bit about
why they help how do we prevent
overfitting this is kind of a big deal
on machine learning in general where we
have a better better fit to our training
data and the new ones seeing data that
we want to operate in
operate with ctk packages module is just
a brief overview of what kinds of things
are available in terms of a we've got to
set up a network we've got to set up a
learning algorithm that sort of thing
Bremner so those things and deep
learning examples including
convolutional neural network and longest
short term memory examples this will be
the core of the talk this is where most
of the notebooks come from so today in
terms of data sets and notebooks there
will be two synthetic data sets and out
of those will have three notebooks the
three notebooks will cover logistic
regression and multi-layer perceptrons
just so you get exposure to what these
things all people mean when they say
these things we will have to image data
set problems to image data sets after
that we will get six notebooks will have
a logistic regression will have an NLP
notebook will have several MLP notebooks
actually and will have should say three
three multi-layer perceptron notebooks
and two convolutional convolutional
neural network notebooks and then will
have five or sorry three texts or three
text problems let's get an overview of
the data sets here oops
[Music]
three text problems and from that we'll
get five notebooks there'll be a
multi-layer perceptron just to ground
ourselves back in the hey look what are
these neural network things about there
will be a convolutional neural network
just so we see how that's applied to
text with what they call word embeddings
we use global vectors can also use word
to vex you will have two notebooks for
long short-term memory solutions and we
will have one final notebook for fast
text
[Music]
all right so those are what we're going
to cover in the next couple of hours
Oh at least the level of laughter is
going down on this good what does the
machine learning alright so how does
Dave define machine learn Dave defines
this machine learning is using data to
create a model and these are
mathematical models so there's going to
be a tiny little bit amount to map one
or more input values to one or more
output values and this has interest from
many groups now you might imagine and
these people have different names from
the same things so for example the
computer scientists call this machine
learning the statistician is called a
statistical learning the engineer is
called this pattern recognition all the
same stuff same themes example
applications object detection I can ask
hey are there people in this image from
a unmanned aerial vehicle speech
recognition what is this person's asking
for when they respond to a voice menu
system translation machine translation
somebody typing email you could send it
somebody in a foreign country and
conceptually have it automatically
translate stuff for you natural language
processing we can track for example
sentiment of tweets that we see on the
Internet gesundheit or the postings that
we see on various social media platforms
recommendations what do we recommend
what kinds of movies would we recommend
what kinds of other products might we
recommend that you buy what kind of news
stories might you be interested in
genomics I remember when I was younger
Mike my child needed a tetanus shot they
asked me to sign a form that said well
this might kill your child so I think
being able to have customized medicines
kind of super important advertising it's
an awesome application where you
automatically get labels right you have
some pool of advertising that you can
choose from to put on your website and
you get feedback from users about
whether they're interested in it by the
clicks that you see or they can go step
further and say
person actually sign up or did this
person purchase whatever it was that was
being advertised finance we can ask
things like what investments look
profitable for the next for the
near-term security we could ask is this
credit card transaction look like it was
generated by Dave in Anguilla for
example or does this look like this is
malware relationships between the things
that we talked about here so it's kind
of like an onion I guess this is from
this deep learning book by a good good
fellow Benjy oh and kohrville a great
book for theory from deep learning and
it's kind of kind of got some nifty
points for the high level aspects too so
in our onion at the outer layer we have
artificial intelligence an example here
is knowledge bases where you might have
heuristic rules expert rules that have
been encoded into making decisions for
you the layer inside of that a subset of
artificial intelligence machine learning
this is where we're trying to get billed
automatically build models to map inputs
to outputs example here they mentioned
our logistic regression others that you
might think of random force or gradient
boosting would be super popular versions
of machine learning today then on the 1
one more layer in we have representation
learning and here they talk about
shallow auto-encoders autoencoder
for example I tried to predict my output
whatever the inputs are to this
multi-layer simple multi-layer
perceptron I try to predict those inputs
as outputs or just the simple single
hidden layer multi-layer perceptron that
we're going to look at expensively kind
of in the next bit of time this fits
here one layer and then we have deep
lying
says example of MLPs so MLPs are what
are called feed-forward networks okay
appiy forward network with one layer you
would call kind of a shallow learner a
few be forward network with multiple
layers we refer to as a deep network and
some of these networks have well over
100 layers right so one of the
competition winners recently was a 151
layer Network for image recognition
alternative to feed-forward networks or
recurrent networks so what is deep
learning same book here on the Left we
have rule-based systems where we have
some input data we have a hand design
program some code encoding of heuristic
rules for example expert rule system and
it make some generate some output what
advertisement should we display the next
level over this is kind of a redundancy
of the previous slide but classic
machine learning again random force
gradient blue theme logistic regression
we have the input data we'll see you
again we'll see examples this one
several data sets they have hand design
features so typically this would come
from structured databases you would have
some kind of mapping from the features
which is our model essentially mapping
the hand hand design features to output
predictions for example class labels for
classification is this malware or not or
numeric values for regression what will
be the temperature tomorrow all right so
under-representation learning again
representation learning is the big deal
about deep learning so a lot of effort a
lot of money goes into this business of
hand design features and machine
learning historically and the problem is
that for perceptual data for exam
or in computer vision image object
detection within images or in speech
recognition it's really hard to come up
with great features although folks have
made Admiral admirable efforts for sure
okay so in the representation line here
in the shallow version on the left here
that I'm circling we have input some set
of features comes in we get a mapping
from these features want to see an
explicit example of this in a few
minutes and that's used to make some
kind of prediction in the deep learning
version of it we not only have that
initial layer of mapping we have
mappings of mappings we have features of
features we can make up multiple levels
of abstraction so I can say for example
at one layer of a network I could say oh
do you see that kind of shape and the
same layer a low-level feature I might
ask you see the shape and then at a
higher level I might ask oh do you see
that shape maybe that's a caviar for
example all right
machine learning taxonomy just so I've
mentioned some of these things
supervised learning this is where we're
hanging out this morning for sure output
is provided for observations used for
training in the case of classification
the output is a cackled categorical
label it belongs to this class it
doesn't belong to this class for example
our focus for today is what they call
discriminative we're not worried about
predicting the probability of observing
this input data parametric models so
parametric means we know the size of the
model before we actually build the model
unsupervised learning this in this
instance output is not provided for
observations used for training a great
example of this is either dimensionality
reduction like some kind of principal
component analysis type thing we're not
going to talk about or customer
segmentation some kind of clustering
semi-supervised learning is kind of in
between the supervised and unsupervised
learning segments output is provided for
some of the observations used for
training and then finally and I should
say that unsupervised learning
typically two purposes for in supervised
learning one is to say huh what does the
data look like can I get a get a handle
on what kinds of things are similar to
other kinds of things in my data with
the representation I have and then for
example if I have clustering output I
can turn that into features for my
supervised training reinforcement
learning so we're not going to talk
about this when we have an example of
this today but I think this will
probably be a big deal on the future so
today they talk about so reinforcement
learning
rewards are provided to provide positive
or negative reinforcement with
exploration used to seek an optimal
mapping from States to actions so these
states to actions you can think of as
inputs to outputs same kind of thing
what you see people talk about is go you
know so we've got a deep learning
solution for go but this business of
exploration we've got a bunch of choices
and we want we like the computer to help
us to see are we missing something could
we provide be providing other
alternatives for our customers that were
not currently doing and can we do that
in an intelligent way I think this will
be a big area for deep learning actually
machine learning in general in the
future all right so we're dersu about
tensors good times
so this says it's background this is a
little bit about linear algebra so the
two kinds of I think that you could
search for math for machine learning and
there's a couple couple of nice
tutorials that gives you a little
background the kinds of math that you
might see here are calculus and linear
algebra
and I guess I should also add statistics
those are the three big areas hello
all right so tensor is just I'm just
giving a bit of terminology that people
use here tensor is just a generalization
of array right so a scalar is just some
number one point two AHA that is a
scalar value a vector is just an array
of one dimensional number of numbers so
one point two two point three three
point four that is a vector a matrix is
a two-dimensional array of numbers so I
could have four point five five point
six six point seven you get the idea
[Music]
that is a two-dimensional array of
numbers a tensor is just the
generalization of this right so you
could refer to the others as tensors
so for scaler you'd say it's a zero
dimensional tensor for a vector e that
the one dimensional tensor for a matrix
it's a two dimensional tensor tensor is
that a generalization that goes to more
than two dimensions examples here are
arrays of images so let's say we have an
image with an array of images with the
red green and blue channels so I took
like three matrix C matrices to fact on
top of each other array of documents
with each word represented by an
embedding we'll look at an example of
that in just a few minutes and one last
word of terminology because this is like
it I think this is kind of at the core
of deep learning this is just Dave's
take on this right your mileage may vary
on everything I say today just so you
know where to shoot about dot products
so this dot product is just us measuring
similarity so we have two vectors for
example one point two two point three
three point four and four point five
five point six six point seven those are
two different vectors
and I can take taken a sum the products
of these two it's like a multiply one by
one point two by four point five add
that to two point three plus or times
five point six add that to three point
four times six point seven why do people
do such a thing what's the big deal
about dot product right this is a
specialized version of inner product
which is just a generalization of top
product this measure similarity between
vectors so when we talk about rolling
things like a filter convolutional
neural network layer filter across an
image we're looking for a particular
pattern and we say do you see it do you
see it do you see it you see it we're
using something like a dot product to do
such a thing
all right so dot product measure is
similar to between two vectors the dot
product is a none normalized version is
a cosine of the angle between two
vectors where the cosine takes on the
maximum volume of plus one is the
positive one if the two vectors point in
the same direction or the cosine takes
on the minimum value of negative one if
they point in the opposite directions
and we'll look at an explicit example of
this in a few minutes that hopefully
should make it Lots getting access to a
platform with a graphics processing unit
graphics processing is often increase
the speed of tensor manipulation by an
order of magnitude sometimes less for
sure but significantly you'll notice the
difference if you use the GPU versus a
central processing unit core and this is
because deep winding consists of easily
paralyzed operations like matrix
multiplication matrix multiplication you
can think of is just a boatload of dot
products so GPUs often have thousands of
processors but they can be kind of
expensive so this is the option we're
going to look at this morning and you're
just playing for a few hours as your is
probably your best bet and that's what
we're going to do we're going to win
someone else's GPU for like 90 cents an
hour alternative if your recurring
hobbyist or your professional you're
probably should consider buying a card
the differences between these cards are
coming versions of core and memory
examples here are GG x 1050 TI you can
get have 768 cours has 4 gigabytes of
memory it cost like $150 we can go down
to Best Buy today probably find it there
and just stick it in a PCI slot in your
computer away you go it's a it's
relatively inexpensive way to go no
special power requirements for the 1050
Ti just plug in play for 10 70 or 1080
Ti they're a little bit bigger card they
consume a little bit more power so
sometimes you think consume up to 150
watts of power right or more and when
they start consuming so much power they
generate a lot of heat when they
generate a lot of heat not only will you
have extra power connectors but you'll
also have extra fan or extra cooling
components to deal with when you do the
installation so it just things to be
aware of and then if you've got the
money Titan XP XP is probably the way to
go
today 3840 cores 12 gigabytes of memory
but $1200 I don't think you'll find that
one at the Best Buy
all right again we'll cover Azure VM
here virtual machine here do not forget
to delete it when you're done those
people would just keep charging you 90
cents an hour whether you using the
thing or not right alright so if you are
going to install your own card for
example go down and buy one of these for
like $700 this fits in again it fits in
the PCI slot here's a link to the user
guide for the card that you're
considering probably should look at the
user guide for and open up your machine
and look before you go purchase but keep
in mind again fancier cards require
extra power slots so here it requires
not only one but two different power
connectors an eight pin and a 6 pin
connector just something to keep in mind
alright so for as you're here is a
pricing details for Azure for an NC 6 a
blue 2 instance it's 90 cents an hour
and that's what I'm using here
everything that I do here
it's a
using the abouttwo nc6 instance it's
like our lowest level instance but it
comes with a nvidia k80 card which
actually comes with two different
graphic processing units and you get to
use one of them for 80 cents an hour if
you go with the Windows version this
works on Windows 2 but if you go with
the Windows version it's like a dollar a
dollar right and so it's like an 18
cents difference whatever okay so as
your sign in you're going to create an
account you go to this portal as ur comm
thing down here when you log in you're
going to get a interface that looks like
this for your dashboard you're going to
click on this virtual machines link the
virtual machines link you're going to
click create virtual machine these are
super simple instructions under aw once
you click that you presented with this
we're going to click Bluetooth server
and we click a Bluetooth server we're
going to click a Bluetooth server 16.04
LTS LTS stands for long-term support
it's probably the way to go
we're going it gives us this window and
we're just going to select the resource
default resource manager deployment mode
when in doubt use the default crate
click the Create button so here I give a
name for the computer
Dada bar - azure I say we want to use
virtual machine disk type hard disk
drive I think I think if you use a
solid-state drive it will not let you
select an nc6 instance so something to
think about
do I have a good reason for that no I
don't have a good reason for that
username I just use my own name you can
use whatever authentication type here I
just use password I would probably
recommend if it's your own device right
your own personal device that you're
going to be using to access this thing I
would probably recommend going through a
little bit of pain with the secure shell
ssh setup because just automatically
logs you in it just trust that aha this
must be Dave does this guy's
authenticated this computer
we'll just use the steward SSH
certificate to do the login all right so
I set up a password on this I confirm my
password subscription you can get like a
200 dollar free trial but to the best of
my knowledge you can't get a GPU
instance on the free trial I actually
have no real reasons of that other than
maybe it's a scarcity issue right so you
have to select pay as you go if you want
to I think if you want to set up a GPU
instance VM all right so create new says
a resource group sure let's call a debar
resource group da big and location us
less to or less us to I think us east
and us south-central also have allow for
GPU instances if you're in doubt you go
to this region's thing here and it will
tell you which regions support GPU
instances alright so we click create we
click OK here for the configure of the
virtual machine it gives us an option it
says do you want a d1 v2 or an a1
instance and I go neither of those so I
click the view all button here on the
right this I scroll down here so we've
scrolled down to the NC stuff and I
choose an NC 6 instance and this is
giving you the monthly rate don't panic
it charges by our alright so NC 6
standard has six cores six CPU cores
it has 56 gigabytes of memory it has
eight data disks 8 by 5 500 maximum i/o
operations per second 338 gigabytes
local SSD interesting load balancing and
1k 80 graphics card that actually gives
you like a half of the kt graphics card
whatever config configure settings so
all here I touch nothing I literally
just went with default and again in
doubt just go with the default all right
and then it gives you a summary of what
you're about to purchase and you click
OK so once it's it takes maybe I don't
know two or three minutes or deploy give
it up to ten minutes if it's still going
after ten minutes hmm maybe refresh the
screen I've never had it go that long so
two or three minutes it comes back with
this interface saying we've deployed
your VM and this is the IP address of
that thing you can actually configure a
domain name if you want for such a thing
we're not going to do that today
so literally I just use IP address IP
address to connect to my as your VM all
right so install installing support
software so once we have obutu
VM setup we log in with the password
that we were given there is in support
software installation directions here
install cuda drivers for NC VMS from the
Microsoft folks to get to the server I
use putty so everything that you see was
generated by initially logging in with
putty which gives us secure shell top
software this is optional if you already
have a secure shell client great just
use that here's the place where you can
download it from when using SSH make
sure I would recommend that you from the
connection configuration option under
SSH and x11 make sure you check the
little box that says enable x11
forwarding this lets you have X window
display for example I'm using a Windows
laptop right I use the windows surface
all the time
even when I'm connecting to my
computer's downstairs at home so I just
use an X Windows Server this X Ming X
Windows Server on my Windows laptop and
project the graphics back using x11
okay configuring the Nvidia driver these
are literally the commands to use so
we're going to grab this CUDA CUDA
stands for Nvidia being a complete
unified device architecture we're
setting up drivers to the graphics
processing card nvidia is the big winner
here could you do Greta could you make
use of GPU some other customers other
companies absolutely but Nvidia is the
big big name in today and deep line
alright so this tells us the name of the
package that we're looking for this is
us going and fetching that package this
is us
installing the package this is us
removing just extra bits whatever is
going like that and this is us doing
updates so this tells it to update the
servers where it gets software from this
tells it to install the cuda drivers and
this tells us to install the cuda
support software when you're done after
you wish literally I just typed those
commands or actually I copied it copied
them from the slide and pasted them into
my putty window here I'm pretty certain
those of the commands you should be able
to run this nvidia - SMI at your command
prompt and you'll get something that
looks like this and this says you've got
a access to a tesla k80 and it says you
have 12 gigabytes of memory
technically each of those processes each
of the GPU units that come with the k80
has 12 gigabytes together becoming four
but you've got half of that alright so
into yeah ok and there's a link to the
specs for the card if you want that one
cost a good bit more even than the Titan
XP so you have to break out your piggy
bank
all right so where to start with the
machine learning stuff a logistic
regression tutorial example this this
picture comes from the Cortana
intelligence library gallery they've got
a collection of cognitive toolkit
tutorials and I just thought it was a
nice picture to give an idea of inputs
outputs or simple example for logistic
regression
and so today that's probably put in
there so over here on the horizontal
axis we have age and years of a person
here on the vertical axis we have tumor
size and centimeters so somebody's
taking some kind of measurement right
the widest possible measure for example
of a tumor some kind of bump right and
we've plotted these points so those are
two dimensions third dimension is color
here so the red dots represent a
positive class malignant tumor and the
blue dot represents the negative class
or benign tumor okay so here they've
drawn this green line this is
essentially a logistic regression model
a decision boundary it says if you're in
this region we think you're a positive
class and if we look at that we see like
10 out of 12 observations or like 83%
maybe 3% of the examples over here are
indeed positive class and if you fall in
this region we think you are negative
class or benign benign tumor so that was
just a simple example of a picture they
drew we will look at some synthetic data
in here second alright so logistic
regression is the Shaolin linear model a
line right so our decision boundaries
drawn by a classification boundaries
drawn by line consists of a single layer
with a single sigmoid activation
function a sigmoid gesundheit
sigmoid activation function Maps
log-odds values to predicted
probabilities
it has kind of an s-shape how it got the
name sigmoid cross-entropy is used as a
loss function the objective used to draw
to drive training or updating the
weights right how do we know how do we
build the model we'll be using the
stochastic gradient descent in our
example today because this is the core
learning you method used for training
deep learning models but most logistic
regression packages use another method
right they use what's called l-bfgs
limited memory boid and Fletcher gold
for channel optimization it's an
approximation of iterative related least
squares but it has this bit where you
have to so iteratively relate at least
squares the downside to it is it's got
this bit where you have to invert a
matrix which is kind of a costly thing
and the larger the feature space the
more of a problem that's going to become
so almost exclusively to castigated the
center orbit or invest that or variant
of it logistic regression model sigmoid
functions use map input features to
predict the probability of class
membership here we have an example this
is our predicted probability P Hat 1
over 1 plus exp negative negative X
transpose W this X is some input vector
this W is some weight vector and this is
just the dot product of those two things
right how similar is this is this input
vector pointing in the same direction as
our weight vector so here this would be
the weight vector for this
classification problem it would be
pointing in this direction and so you're
asking are anything that points in the
same direction is this weight vector
it's positive class anything that points
in the opposite direction it's the
negative class ok
alright there's words that just say the
same thing I think
alright so learning by gradient descent
the gradient of loss functions use the
update the length of the model we'll
look at implementation in Python of
course the gradient of loss function
tells us how to maximize loss function
yes I said maximize seems like we want
to minimize the loss function so we're
going to take the negative of the
gradient or just subtract off the
gradient to minimize the loss function
cross entropy loss function this is the
most popular thing for classification
today and deep learning this function is
used to measure the similarity between
two distributions in the context of
evaluating pattern recognition models or
pattern recognitions and relating for
classification models we are using this
function to measure the de similarity of
the target class indicator and predict
the probability for each class so here
we have our predictive probabilities and
here we have an indicator of whether you
actually belongs to that class over the
classes and the observations and your
data set so this sum negated of course
because otherwise it would be going up
right the negated version of that sum is
log loss or another name for that is
cross entropy alright so gradient
descent for logistic regression
here are some nasty math symbols we
won't spend too much time with this it's
got the little jelly roger there in the
lower left hand corner across the cross
entropy function the function used for
evaluating the quality of a prediction
can be expressed as follows so we say
this negative log probability of it
belongs to this class given our input
data X and our model weight weight
vector W this can be translated to this
these two are equivalent so literally
this is our predicted probability if
it's belongs to that class y sub I star
is 1 and this is the probability redic
to probability or 1 minus the
probability of positive class membership
if it does not belong to this class
so only one of these two Lysa by star or
one - why simple I star only one of
those two is going to be one the other
will drop to zero which is effectively
remove that term all right so this
becomes is the same as being as this
which is the same thing as this here
we're just saying ah you know what this
to the minus one I can just pull out the
minus one cancels that thing out and so
this is this is the loss function we'll
be working with in practice so y sub I
star is 0 1 y sub I is negative 1 1 in
the next four slides
all right gradient descent part 2
derivative of loss function with respect
to parameter in case how to update my
weights to optimize loss function this
is our gradient symbol this is the
gradient of this loss function with
respect to our weight vector W the
weight from one update our model this is
the vector partial derivatives right
partial derivatives with each of the
weights in our model so for example in
the two dimensions we'd have a weight
for each dimension plus a bias cone the
machine learns on quote by updating the
models to minimize the loss function all
right so we update by subtracting the
product of the input feature value and
the difference between the predicted
probability and the class membership
indicator and what this is this is a
harkens back to the chain rule from
calculus but essentially it's this is
our predictive probability P hat - the
indicator whether belong to this class
or didn't belong to this class it was
malignant or as benign right 1 or 0 and
this is the actual input data so the
product does of this difference and the
input data tells us how to update a
weight in our model and this is true in
general for our deep learning alright uh
shall we steps of differentiation for
completeness yeah yeah yeah looks better
over on your own email me if you got
questions
oh oh by the way so I rip this off from
derivative calculator net right so most
most of you probably don't do this
day-to-day otherwise you probably
wouldn't be in the room I don't know but
so if I want to if I want to develop
some new super cool loss function right
for my graduate work or something then I
can I can feed my loss function into
something like derivative calculator net
to find out what derivative what I use
to update my weights all right so let's
stick regression example as a network
viewed as a network there is a simple
input layer of pre-processed features
and there is an output layer with a
sigmoid activation function so literally
we're going to take the dot products of
this input vector and some weight vector
here and feed that through our logistic
function to get an estimated probability
of positive class membership so this is
our first example to cast a gradient
descent in Python to fire up the jupiter
notebook your download anaconda you type
in dollar home anaconda three-bin
jupiter space notebook it'll come up
with a list of notebooks for you you
select o one SGD like so
oh all right
so in block one here so each of these
things right we have some boxes actually
there's the block at the top it gives a
name to the notebook just a simple
markdown expression that says what this
notebook is about so the first one is
simple stochastic gradient descent line
1 from block 1 initialization important
um pi is MP from matplotlib import PI
plot is PLT it's allows us to do some
visualization percent matplotlib in line
allows us to do the visualization inside
the notebook MP random seed makes things
makes us stuff repeatable all right so
block 2 we're going to generate some
data so there's going to be in this
numpy concatenate we're going to
generate two different classes of data
no our multivariate normal essentially
just two dimensions down here right
where I have in the upper right hand
corner I have the positive class the red
X's and in the lower left-hand corner I
have the negative class or the blue X's
so our negative class is centered at
negative 3 negative 3 over here or a
coordinate and it has a we're using
essentially what's called an identity
matrix for our covariance right so it
just says it has a unit a a single unit
standard deviation in both directions
okay and then we generate ten points for
the negative class and our positive
class is centered at 3 3 so 3 3 and we
generated another 10 with the same
identity matrix for for covariance all
right so we make a Y vector of 10 zeros
and 10 ones for the negative class in
the positive class labels we plot them
just get a picture of what they look
like we have here I'm initializing your
rate manually typically you would do
this
the rent randomly initialized to small
values here I'm initializing Xin
negative 0.02 negative point a 1 and 0
and I'm printing the vector just so you
can see this is actually pointed in the
wrong direction so our class here would
actually be along this line right
between the two classes this is where
our decision boundary would lie and our
weight vector should actually be
pointing in this direction pointing in
the same direction as the positive class
okay so by giving it something starts
off with negative numbers here I'm
actually pointing it in the wrong
direction we want to see can it overcome
it
alright uh predict probability this is
that sigmoid function 1 over 1 plus exp
negative XP is Euler's number 2.71828
dot product between our input values in
our weight vector and so P is our
predicted probabilities for those data
that we just generated taking our inputs
our data in our weight vector and here
we're printing the predicted
probabilities so for the first 10
observations which are the negative
class we see it actually is above 0.5
and for the next 10 we see its boil
point 5 and that's because the weight
vector is pointed in the wrong
directions
all right so some weight update a simple
weight of a update example so here we
are with the J is 1 this is just us um
this is just us saying which index to
use from our data set I'm just using one
that could view 0 whatever so print the
printout input values negative to
negative point negative 4i print the
output value which is 0 the actual class
membership value which is 0 print the
weight vector which is the same thing we
initialized it to I predict print the
predicted probability which is above 0.5
which is wrong of course
I predict print compute gradient the
gradient here as we mentioned before is
just our prediction oops
though it's just our prediction 1 over 1
plus exp negative dot product between
the input and the lead vector minus the
actual class indicator 0 or 1 times
input values all right so this is me
printing the the computed gradient this
is me printing the updated weight vector
W minus the computer gradient and this
is me printing the predicted probability
with that updated leg vector using W
minus compute gradient and we see that
our predictive probability at the end of
that is 0 did the right thing all right
all right so one ear 8.5 epochs 5000
epoch is just an iteration through the
entire data set we only have 20
observations index here I'm just
building index of for the observations
and then I'm shuffling that index to do
this is the stochastic part of gradient
descent randomly selected one
observation at a time ok for each of the
observations we just were doing updates
to the weight vector ok
so we're rolling through the data doing
updates to the weight vector this is me
generating the predicted probabilities
and this is me printing out the epoch
the iteration through the data the loss
function of the log loss as well as the
weight vector so here we start off with
0 with our log loss of 0.01 6 and our
weight vector is 0.92 1.1 4 and by the
end of a thousand epochs we get down to
$49.99
we're have five zeros after the decimal
point you negative point of u- o six so
point zero zero zero zero zero nine one
two seven the cool interesting thing to
note about this is it keeps going down
over here okay and the reason it keeps
going down is because our weights keep
getting larger because the log loss that
we're feeding into our a sigmoid or simi
our weight
yeah our log odds that we're feeding
into the sigmoid function are
continually growing which is going to
cause the problem in terms of our video
I had a question about the shuffle part
we're guessing you did that because it's
a category and it's a not batch right
right if you did mini-batch would you
have to also shuffle it oh no you should
wind up the same same answer because
you're going to go through all the data
um okay so there's three variants right
right there's a stochastic gradient
descent proper where you do them one at
a time
there is a batch gradient descent where
you doing them all doesn't matter
because the the the product of the
differences between the predictions
because the weight were weights were
frozen before he started this iteration
with the best gradient descent so the
difference is it doesn't matter which
order you process and then because it'll
still be the same weight vector she
started on the epoch with so and the
input values will still be the same so
the some of the things total thing but
if you're doing mini batch would like
batches like 120 yeah then it matters
yep all right oh all right so our
weights grow our weights will continue
to grow if we don't regularize them all
right so what do we mean by
regularization all stochastic gradient
descent so computing regularize loss
here we're going to add this extra charm
for loss we're going to add 1/2 times
some weight decay rate parameter times
the squared weights okay and you notice
that I have two of my three entries in
my weight vector here
I have the weights for the both of the
inputs but not the bias term the bias
term is not regular eyes typically I
have not seen anybody do that in an
implementation but the idea here is that
by taking the gradient of that of that
weight component right where we're
adding this the squared weights to our
loss value by taking the the and
subtracting the gradient of that thing
essentially we're just saying take a
small proportion of the weight and move
it closer to zero whatever way you have
let's move it a little bit closer to
zero if it was a negative weight a
little toward zero if it was a positive
weight a little toward zero subtracting
off or adding off that's appropriate and
so what we wind up here with the
regularize version after 5 after
actually all it's a thousand iterations
how many generations Diane's five
thousand something like this five
thousand bucks after a thousand
iterations we're pretty much got our
final vector right so one point three
one point one point three for the first
input 1.0 for the second and negative
0.5 for the bias and it stays the same
all throughout and the idea behind the
regularization
[Music]
it's thinking
[Music]
[Music]
having the page here
[Music]
back let's say that we had instead of
[Music]
linearly separable classes we have this
situation where there's a little bit of
overlap so rarely we see an observation
that crosses over the line what we don't
want to have happen is our weights to
grow to infinity because that will
continue to minimize that log loss if it
left unchecked and have a value where
it's just on this side of the line then
oh yes that's definitely negative class
over here but if it crosses just a
little bit over it says times positive
infinity oh that's definitely positive
we don't want a small change in inputs
to lead to a large change in outputs
that's a typical behavior that we see
associated with what they call
overfitting
all right so going through stratified
and gradient descent as we mentioned
earlier to cast a gradient set one at a
time Batz gradient sent all them at the
same time mini-batches a popular thing
it's actually the most popular thing
some set at a time right so 64
observations their time 128 observations
at time that sort of thing
gradient descent can also be stratified
by a couple other along a couple other
dimensions there could be a momentum
term the idea here is to take advantage
of the fact that the surface the
decision surface that were or the
surface that were climbing down for
minimizing our loss function isn't the
same along all dimensions so maybe some
dimensions we want to travel faster than
others so with the okay so I'm sorry
that's adaptive gradient adaptive
gradients there is a version of the
gapped of gradients depth of gradients
not used so much there's a small
slightly better version this called root
mean square propagation so this is a
form of adaptive gradients with
normalization of the gradients momentum
is a way of us avoiding hopefully
avoiding local minima because in deep
learning there is no such thing as a
context law surface so there's lots of
little bumps right what we're doing is
hoping for
a relatively good bump right then we get
in a relatively low loss situation the
momentum the idea is to use the previous
updates a weighted combination of the
current gradient plus the the previous
gradients to keep traveling in the same
kind of direction hope hope of avoiding
local minima if possible to get to
global Optima all right
multi-layer perceptron example here we
have just three layers input layer a
hidden layer and output layer so these
guys themselves can be sigmoid so this
is a sigmoid this is a sigmoid this
isn't a sigmoid
all right so here is our our same
Network same little network that we
looked at here I've defined the sigmoid
function 1 over 1 plus exp negative X
here I have a bias input 1 input 2 a
bias is always 1 right it's just an
extra term to add to change the output
value
that's being fed into some activation
function like a sigmoid bias term input
1 and input 2 terms and a target this
says this is a positive class
observation with the x value being 1 the
first dimension being 1 value being 1
the second dimension going to be a
negative 1 here is us here's definition
of a network here where we have
[Music]
this first block is wait for that first
hidden layer neuron the second block
line six through eight our weights for
the second hidden layer neuron and this
final is the weights for the output
neuron okay all three of these are going
to be sigmoid activation functions all
right so forward propagation of input
features through the data so wanted to
manually step through we're just doing
dot products right dot product of the
first line lying to their dot product of
the input values one negative one with
our hidden weights hidden layer weight
hidden node one activation or wait in
layer node one weight and then
activation of hidden hidden layer one
node is just the sigmoid vet dot product
same thing four four and five for that
second object second node here's us
printing the to activation outputs block
five here is us doing the activation
between the two hidden layer nodes so
with the line two there is the dot
product of the two of the two features
from the hidden layer plus the
activation output and then line six here
or block six rather is us updating the
weights for the output layer okay I
think that in the interest of time I'm
going to start going a little bit faster
but the idea is that we're applying the
gradients to these things okay so we
take the derivative is loss and the
derivative of the output activation
function on top line seven eight I'm
copying off the previous weight values
the storm I'll need those in a minute to
back propagate some data and then I'm
updating the weights for the output
neuron in lines 10 through 12 and here
here are us printing the updated weights
so I updated to be funky right
so my initialization was pointed 1.0 2.0
3.0 4 etc and what I see here is in the
case of the three weights here it was a
0.0 7.0 8.0 9 in in this case it's
increased all free weights which is the
right thing because it's going to
increase the activation out for the
sigmoid because we wanted to say that
it's positive class membership all right
so here is us back propagating error
these are derivatives from the hidden
layer and these derivatives there's an
appendix saw on a slide for our deck
that gives the derivation of this P
times 1 minus P seeing our derivative of
activation here is us updating the
weights for the hidden first hidden
layer or first hidden layer node and
here is us updating the weights for the
second hidden layer node and printing
out the weights and what we see is the
weights that increased are the positive
things so the bias term increase the
positive input value the wait for that
increased the negative input value it
decreased by decreasing that we're
taking a step toward saying you know
what let's have a little bit more
positive output for this activation
function which actually turns out to be
the right thing and that happens for the
second chidden layer neuron as well all
right and so then we check our
prediction here is us doing the forward
propagation again and now we get instead
of originally our prediction was up
originally our predicted output was
point five three eight it is now 0.5 for
two so we're moving in the right
direction because this is a positive
class observation PI point five for two
is better than point five three eight in
terms of our our loss function I predict
the probability of pulse class
membership is in fact larger we have
learned something
all right back propagation description
this thing we're not going to spend time
on but again from the theoretical
perspective this deep learning book
awesome it everybody it takes everybody
a long time to read through such a thing
don't don't panic the best bet if you're
doing this on your own is to try to get
your try to convince your friends to
join a reading group right so that you
can go through the misery together if
you're reading ten pages a day don't
sweat it
I mean that seriously is totally awesome
actually right if you're reading more
than ten pages a day out of the book
you've probably done this for a while
then alright so installing tea and tea K
so we installed Nvidia drivers earlier
now we're going to start using cindy
kaye in our final hour here alright so
here I am just using the stuff from
setup Linux binary manual I sudo apt-get
install open MPI bin message passing
interface binary I get the anaconda
three 4.1.1 installation I got this one
because this one this page says this is
the version they tested with probably
want to go with the version they tested
with actually relatively stable I think
you probably actually know better than I
do but I mean I'm just plain too safe
I'm going with the version they say they
used we install that one right so here's
me calling bin bash with this Sh that I
downloaded to install anaconda this is
the responses I get you know basically
I'm just pressing in or to go through
right let's read the license let's
scroll through the license
let's enter yes that we accept the
license in terms
a personal decision press ENTER to take
the default installation directory I did
that and enter yes to prepend Python to
your program search path so that you
don't have to keep playing Oh where's
pythons here's us actually installing cm
TK so literally I am using in version 3
5 and this page says these two guys go
together so I'm just using this WHL file
we will file two with pip to do the
installation all this stuff is super
quick the reason why I didn't want to do
it with you today is because I was
worried that so many people with all of
us on the Wi-Fi cost problems who knows
things here I'm installing a browser
because I'm going to point it back to my
instance at home on my Windows surface
alright so MLP example within CNG k now
we're going to start rolling through
rings now we're going to start doing
high level stuff alright so here is us
importing Ct KSC that's just a name
space right a cognitive tool kit name
space mat pot lid because we want to
visualize stuff right and numpy and seed
so we get some some repeatability here
I've made a separate a different data
set so here we have our positive class
is the Reds right over here Center get
negative 3 3 and negative 3 3 & 3
negative 3 so our red our 2 red X groups
are a positive class and our 2 blue X
groups are our negative class and now
where's your linear deity right there's
no way to actually get a single line to
separate those guys those two classes so
this is what representation learning is
all about we want to have the computer
tell us what features
yes yes we were hiring people right
probably what you would do is spend
spend some money domain experts would
get together and they would be able to
look at this milk well you know what we
can see it we can multiply we can take
the interaction of this first feature
and the second feature we just multiply
them together right if it's negative one
it's positive class if it's positive one
it's negative class that's simple but we
had to hire somebody to do the feature
engineering for us well we'd like to get
the computer to do some feature
engineering force all right so here is
me declaring the input feature count is
2 the output class count is 2 here's me
declaring a couple of operands input
variables input based on the input
feature count on input variable based on
the output feature count a label
variable class label variable is going
to positive or negative class here is us
declaring the model hidden feature count
we're going to have to that same the
same pretty backpropagation network that
we looked at just a second ago this is
precisely the network for defining okay
all right so sequential network
consisting of two layers two dense
layers lines 3 & 4 here the first
insulator has hidden feature count to 2
nodes and we are initializing using this
again we're easing the layers package
from cognitive toolkit glow rot uniform
glow Raja said you know what we should
have a distribution with a mean of 0 but
our variance should be relatively small
it should be based on the size of our
network layer all right the size of the
network layers so based on this guy is
heuristic Laura it's heuristic we're
going to use a uniform distribution with
Clorox heuristic to initialize these and
small values really small values um
actually it's not such a such a large
network so maybe it's not so so small
bit you know
Jenya 0.01 0.02 dark iving activation
we're going to use the sigmoid that we
know and love from from earlier and
we're going to call this hidden layer so
we can actually access the the weights
from it later otherwise I don't I never
named these things okay we're going to
define a second dense layer here online
for output class count also two so here
for it's going to have two output nodes
essentially we're using the softmax
which is a so our activation value that
we used earlier was this actually it was
a X transpose weight let this sigmoid
activation function
is equivalent of
[Music]
this softmax activation function
these two guys are the same when you
talk about difficulty of reading
people's papers and things I remember in
the 90s some guy had used this without
the half so we started using too here
I'm like how did you get a two so X
transpose W X transpose W you get the
idea these two are equivalent except one
has one node the other has two nodes
right so we're using the softmax and our
network is prone tries by input that is
the input for our network function our
loss we're going to clear from the
losses library or losses package rather
cross entropy with softmax we know
across central use our metrics we're
going to use classification error what
proportion of things did you get wrong
learning rate we're going to use a
that's a relatively high learning rate
this is of the step we're taking a step
in the direction of the gradient this
says how old are you should our step be
point five is kind of large but we'll go
with it for now you know typically you
might see start off with something you
could start off with something large and
decay over time which is a typical
strategy but here we're just setting it
to 0.5 learning rate schedule here we're
saying the C setting up a learning rate
schedule from the learners we are saying
we're going to use to cast a gradient
descent on line 9 and line 10 we're
going to use this trainer with our model
or network or loss function or
evaluation metric and our learner okay
stochastic gradient is sent so this 10
defines our training regimen right how
are we going to try and build this model
are we going to learn the map inputs to
outputs all right so
[Music]
in the Box live Here I am just
concatenated these things I'm generating
random data each time right because
opposed to having a fixed data set which
we'll see in a few minutes and I'm
building a Y vectors where each each row
in the Y matrix has two columns one for
the positive class and one for the
negative class and only one of them will
be one it'll be zero right
so that's what those lines do and then
we call trainer train mini-batch that's
essentially what we're doing here we're
saying for a hundred deep ox line to
call train on train mini bats with that
data set that we generate each time okay
and here is us looking at the loss
reduction starts off at point seven and
it goes down to log loss goes down to
point 2 and our error starts off on
maybe batch zero our error is 0.5 but by
the end of mini batch 48 our error
classification error is zero so how how
would such a thing work with the
sigmoids right so here is me printing
the the weights out from the hidden and
output layers here is me printing the
actual features that were derived from
the hidden layer because in time so the
input matrix times that weight matrix
for that hidden layer is 2 hidden layer
neurons 2x2 matrix gives us the output
beat the the derived features from the
network and here we see the derived
features it kind of looks like the data
is smiling at us right the idea is that
we now have a linearly separable surface
so the neural network took our linearly
inseparable data and transformed it into
a linearly separable problem for us okay
and that is the magic of representation
learning
all right um
we talked about that activation
functions we looked at sigmoid logistic
this morning hyperbolic tangent is also
a super popular hyperbolic tangent here
red instead of going from zero to one
like the blue the sigmoid function it
goes from negative one to one and it has
a similar shape the big one that enabled
deep learning one of the enabling
factors besides the adaptive gradient
self right one of the enabling factors
and tweaks like root mean square
propagation wanted the factors that
enable deep learning was this rectified
linear unit so one of the things that
you see about our hyperbolic tangent and
our sigmoid is they have a property
called saturation over here on the left
and over here on the right if you make a
small change in input essentially no
change in output saturated okay oh where
is not true for the rectified linear
unit which turns out to be a big deal
okay so for the rest of this tutorial
I'm going to go through examples of
Karass why Kerris because it works with
CNG guys is he
caris is on top of CNT k and we didn't
find results for CNG K in the book there
is a free book online for CNT K however
it hasn't been updated in a good bit of
time and I would think that maybe maybe
on amazon.com we can fix this problem
with this hopefully you'll go forth and
write seen GK books who knows but in the
meantime there are Karis books write
this book in this book this book here
the deep learning with Python by this
francoise shall show leg I I recommend
that right from an applied perspective
forget the math don't don't get too
bogged down in all the little little
symbols that we just went through I
highly recommend this book alright so
installation of tariffs is also simple
this was seen TK we cloned the Charis
repository git repository
change directed cares Python set up
install literally copied pasted these
from the slide into my window and
everything worked export cares back-end
equals c mtk you should add this to a
char c ok so that it updates the backend
to use c NT k every time
other other backends that you might
might consider easy pincer pincer flow
from google or piano from university of
montreal okay is your alternatives but
we're how about CT candice mine alright
same CDV examples python amnesty MLP
just to get up and running and have it
do something for you right
alright so documentation for Karis you
can find here and this book deep
learning with Karis the first book and I
didn't double star or whatever it is
also a reasonable book and this guy mmm
they're nice they're nice little
examples where he has a validation data
set so for example in the network's you
can ask how many layers should I have in
my network how many nodes should be in
each layers of this deep learning model
alright these are these are architecture
questions that you have to wrestle with
alright so how can we choose well we use
a separate holdout validation data set
right and say alright so what if we have
64 nodes in our and one layer where do
we get for a result what if we have 128
nodes and two layers what do we get for
a result and you're bouncing this
against the validation data to say which
performed better so this guy was kind of
more it seems I had the impression but
he's a little more careful with that so
they're they're kind of nice examples
plus he has this young because guys
limit Lynette I highly recommend that
you you click on this link the Lynette
link so this is from a guy named
yarmulke
is I guess in charges well AI Facebook
he is the guy who came up attributing
the the success of convolutional neural
networks to this guy and his application
of it to this eminent data problem
m-miss dancer modified National
Institutes of Standards and Technology
data set and the idea is that somebody
has always segmented or drawn boundary
bounding boxes around handwritten
characters for us the Postal Service was
US Postal Service was interested in
automated routing of letters and they
needed to do handwritten recognition of
the zip codes to figure out hey what
city are we sending this to right what a
post office so if I look at a matrix the
pixels here
from the matrix our values between 0 and
255 and I think you can probably
hallucinate that there's a 3 in there
right so we have larger larger values
along here which indicate places where
somebody has put ink on our background
alright so from the end this data
there's a boatload of tutorials here
first one is logistic regression Here I
am importing stuff this is similar to C
and TK right
teres actually comes with a bunch of
data sets which is really nice actually
it doesn't come with the data sets but
when you try to invoke it you say low
data set it will go out and fetch the
data set from the internet for you so
you should have an internet connection
when you do such a thing everything that
I downloaded here today I think is less
than 1 gigabyte total ok word embeddings
kind of kind of put it's a kind of a
kind of way on our budget there come to
that in a minute
alright so models sequential model it's
a feed-forward network one layer after
the other we're going to have a dense
layer in an activation use some
activation stuff ah to cast a gradient
descents what we're going to use for
this first go-around and we're going to
have some I don't think keys as
utilities here but maybe he does I don't
know oh yeah he does he's it to do one
hot encoding for the class labels so our
class labels here are the digits 0
through 9 right
so to get an output matrix so the input
matrix is those pixel values right
arrays are those two-dimensional arrays
of those pixel values the output will
have let's say it's a 3 so a 0 for the 0
a 0 for the 1 0 for the - a 1 for the
three you get the idea and then zeroes
for the other 5 degrees so this is one
row that says aha the first output is a
3 ok
oh so that's what he's using MPU tilts
or here all right I set a seed for that
repeatability the guy from the deep
learning with carousel actually uses
that number of epochs 200 bad sides 128
verbose just says send stuff to the out
screen for me number of classes is 10
because it's a number of digits
optimizer willing to use to start off a
stochastic gradient descent number of
hidden nodes 128 so this is
[Music]
number of weights hop
[Music]
I don't think so I think that uh I
copied this literally I copied this so
the number of hidden nodes you wouldn't
have that for logistic regression okay
for logistic regression we're just going
to have a weight for each of the inputs
right just X X transpose times that
weight vector gives us some output and
we're going to have ten ten nodes one
for each of our classes all right uh
that's religious regression so it loops
it says Justin from the author there and
this load data again this will fit fetch
the data off the internet for us reshape
784 so they start out this is a 28 by 28
matrix if we reshape it into one big
long vector one row after the other it
is 28 times 28 is 77 and 84 all right so
we have 784 this will to carry us
through for this in multi logistic
regression multi-layer perceptron
becomes convolutional neural networks me
a little bit different so we reshape the
two-dimensional pixel matrices into
one-dimensional arrays for future inputs
outputs are those down here block four
eight nine ten outputs are the one hot
encoding of the class labels here we
have normalization here we're dividing
by 255 this is kind of the equivalent of
taking domain knowledge and saying you
know what we say X sub I some input
value minus 0 that's the minimum
possible value over 255 that's excuse me
turn 55 the maximum possible pixel value
minus 0 I can scratch out the - zeros
here so I'm just dividing the values by
255 because numbers between 0 and 1 so
normalization is a typical strategy a
lot so min/max normalization is popular
as you see here all right so this is -
man this is max
mrs. man so is subtracting off the mean
and dividing by the standard deviation
in fact not only can you normalize the
inputs to your initial data for initial
data for example the pixel values you
could also normalize the features that
are derived in intermediate layers and
they refer to this as batching
normalization
all right here we're building in blocks
5 here we're building a model
[Music]
line four declare a sequential model
line five I'm adding a dense layer based
on the number of classes so there will
be ten nodes one one output node for
each class and our activation function
is going to be softmax that e to the x
over the sum of e to the x's for each of
our classes you can think of them as
log-odds weights for each of the classes
it's keeping track of via the magic
against a category descent here is us
printing a model summary which gives us
an idea of the number of weights here's
us compiling the model which essentially
is us telling it here's the optimizer to
use here's the metrics I'd like you to
keep track of here's the loss function
that you're using to optimize for
history we're just recording the history
from output from this model fitting
process we feed it the train vectors and
the test vectors we say batch size is
some small number of observations and
number of epochs is the number of
training epochs to carry out and the
validation split we're going to use 20%
of the training data for holdout for
validation for tuning things like hey
what if we added a layer to the network
what if we change how the network
activation function alright so here we
see we our model has moral model summary
says there are seven hundred eighty
seven thousand seven hundred fifty
parameters that is 784 plus one for the
bias times ten that's how they get 78
fifty all right so the thing for
logistic regression it thinks it's going
to make a bunch of linear models for the
classes
it goes through our 200 epochs printing
out loss functions the first pair of
loss and accuracy values is from the
training data the second pair is for the
holdout validation data and we see that
we're getting into the 90s in terms of
accuracy okay so our volunteer see at
the end is 0.9 two three eight and our
test actor see on the holdout test data
so the data set split up into sixty
thousand training data and ten thousand
test data so on the ten thousand the
holdout test examples we get ninety nine
ninety two twenty five percent point at
ninety two point twenty five percent
accuracy on class labels for the holdout
test images that is logistic regression
multi-layer perceptron same kind of
thing except we're going to define the
network slightly differently here it's a
sequential model feed-forward model
again we're adding a dense layer with
some number of hidden nodes I think we
said 128 right looks like you just
copied and pasted from the previous
thing rectified linear unit is our
activation function as opposed to the
sigmoid another dense layer of 128
activation functions so it has two
hidden layers so this is our first deep
learning network it's also it can have
features built upon top of features this
is the essence of deep learning some of
these people again
have networks with well over 100 layers
but does take a good bit of time
training all right so I'm in the final
so there's three layers here essentially
three layers first is a hidden layer 128
nodes with rectified linear news second
hidden layer again hidden 128 written
nodes rectified linear units and then
ten output classes this is the number of
parameters that you get for each of
these things and the accuracy went from
90 to 0.25 to 94 for nine so MLP bought
us a little here drop out says so one
method of regularization is adding that
weight penalty right doing the weight
decay that we talked about earlier you
can use either the the sum of absolute
weights in l1 regularization term or the
sum of squared weights in l2
regularization term for
that an alternative method to help
prevent overfitting is dropout so here
same multi-layer perceptron except we've
added a couple of dropout layers after
each of the feature layers and what the
dropout layer does is it's randomly
select some set some subset of the
features and zeros amount varying
training okay when it does that it's
going to zero out some proportion of
them typically a range from 10% 50%
something like this your mileage may
vary and when it zeros does out it's
going to have to increase its going to
simultaneously increase the values of
the other other outputs from that hidden
layer so that it can compensate because
while we're dropping out at training
time so it doesn't look at the training
data we do not drop out at test time
okay all right so we have a dropout and
we go from
[Music]
we go from ninety four or four nine to
ninety seven seven eight so now we're
actually going better than k nearest
neighbor on this state uh from Earth ki
near stammer alright so that helped out
a good bit ah
the next thing root-mean-square
propagation so this previous version had
250 epochs that's a lot of epochs after
20 epochs 20 iterations through the data
mini-batch our accuracy was at point
nine four well with root-mean-square
propagation again this is about paying
attention
adaptive gradient method where we're
normalizing gradients are enduring
updates only twenty iterations and we
get a similar comparable accuracy okay
we're able to get to the answer faster
that's the point
so stochastic gradient descent it's a
variant just to guess the gradient
descent that's not exactly the same
thing just so you know alright the next
one
finally our convolutional neural network
all right so I'll tell you what
Wow
or a convolutional neural network what
we're taking is we're going to take a
filter called a chronal here on this
picture I ripped off from from this
place everything here was stolen from
somewhere else almost everything I
responders although all the good stuff
ones to these people all that's not
belongs to me look this kernel we're
doing is a dot product of the with the
elements that are matched to this kernel
and putting the result in the center
ok so we're rolling rolling the filter
around our matrix and we're so for
example a filter might look like this
and what this says is we're rolling this
filter around saying did you see a line
with a positive slope right did you see
the side the line did you see it did you
see it to see and we're just moving it
one step at a time across your image and
then down ok so we're creating a new
output response map for this stuff so
the output response map quantifies the
filters responsible locations within the
image I'm going to go ahead and show you
this picture because I think it's kind
of cool
I was worried about the Wi-Fi thing
[Music]
so this is young because Lynette all
right so this is his convolutional
neural network he has five layers he has
a convolution layer one three and five
and here it's showing you the response
maps okay that he gets for this these
convolutions and here here are the
outputs over here it's showing the input
here and it's showing the answers up
here it's kind of cool to see what what
kinds of things that highlights as it
goes through processing to define such a
thing in terms of Karis on top of CNT K
[Music]
I'm just going to roll to the important
part we are no longer reshaping the data
number one
there is this little bit in this guy's
code from deep learning with Karis where
he says if this is a image data format
is channels first or reshape the data
okay 12 3 14 12 to 14 or something you
might see four theöto back-end for CNT K
back end you will not so we're going to
actually be 16 through 18 we're not
we're not reshaping it to one big vector
we're going to keep the two-dimensional
matrix for the convolution purposes here
so let's roll to the part where it
actually defines the convolution it's a
feed-forward network we have a
convolutional layer with a 3x3 kernel so
we're essentially learning what features
are important right what kinds of what
kinds of things should we look for to
distinguish a 7 from a 3 right so maybe
diagnol line actually has something to
do with that so we had the first
convolution layer he has the second
convolutional layer immediately after
that and that's because we're using
Francois chalets code Heaney is very
cool and as much as he's showing you
some of the latest and greatest stuff
and sometimes that might be a little bit
harder to follow but hey it is what it
is he adds another so the first
convolutional layer consists of 32
shelters 32 little masks separate masks
of size three by three the second
convolutional layer consists of 64
filters also three by three and that is
kind of typical but normally what you
see between the convolution layers is
this max pooling so what we can say so
let's say our response map looks like
this so now we can use this 2x2 thing
and say alright well does the largest
dot max pool says for this two by two a
region what was the max response you saw
for a diagonally here all right
let's let's make that I omit one in this
new matrix but it'll be smaller will be
half the size in fact because the
strides are to my Australia stride equal
to I mean we take this filter instead of
moving over one position move it over
two positions to do the next one so
that's why we see down here we see 24 by
24 images the reason why we see okay so
the first convolution filter drops off
the edges because that 3 by 3 filter
he's saying let's let's ignore the upper
corner so it's getting rid of a row and
a column from each end of the matrix
right so our 28 by 28 becomes 26 by 26
when we do the convolution when we do
the next convolution 26 by 26 becomes 24
by 24 and then when we do the max
pulling that 2 by 2 it has the size of
our image 12 12 by 12 okay all right so
you then add a drop out layer 25% drop
out he flattens the data so it's just
one big happy vector for a dense layer
of rectified linear units ads drop out
of 50% so 50% of the features they're
randomly dropped to zero and then he
rolls it through a dense soft max output
layer
all right so this is if you wanted to
count up how do i type in model summary
here and tells us about the number of
parameters in the output shape down here
in the little text below if you wanted
to figure out how you get the parameter
counts
I give an examples examples here some
examples in the notebook I probably
won't go over too much more here today
but so in the first case 32 let's say
line 14 do a description of one of them
for posterity sake
there are 32 filters there is one input
channel because it's just black or white
from the end this data won't always be
true and just a second we'll see red
green blue so it could be three channels
one for red one for green one for blue
pixels get the idea 3x3 is the size of
the filter son is 32 of those filters
for one input channel and there's a bias
one bias so this is the saw this thing
in parentheses is the size of the dot
product that represents each element in
the output response now okay we're
learning ways to say did you see this
did you see this as you see this these
for these different kinds of features
diagonal lines horizontal line vertical
lines you get the idea and then we can
compose those features to make up a
higher level abstraction like Caviar's
alright so in this case we went from 97%
tune over 99% to actually 99 oh one
which is kind of interesting
I just mentioned this in passing he says
he gets gets up to ninety-nine point two
five too bad we don't see that the
reason why we don't see that for those
variants all right so the reason we
don't see that is because Francois
doesn't set seeds so your mileage may
vary but it should be close it should be
really close alright sif are 10
[Music]
Canadian Institute for Advanced Research
gesundheit
we have ten classes of data and we have
instead of 28 by 28 grayscale pictures
we have 32 by 32 color pictures so it's
32 by 32 by 3 right 1 for red one for
green one for blue so these are examples
of pictures from the syph our 10 data
set all right 10 classes go to the place
where we set up the network
root-mean-square propagation is probably
a good default learning method for this
stuff okay so the cooler malas memory
padding equals same just says you know
what I want the upper left hand corner
for example just zero so everything
doesn't actually match in the filter on
to a valid pixel so convolution to deal
convolution 3x3 rectified linear units
for the convolution as opposed to just
the dot product 32 3 but another 30 to
3x3 convolution with rectified linear
units max pooling 2d sighs - by - max
point
dropped out 25 percent that is the first
block ii dub block convolution 64 of
those 3 by 3 filters another layer of 64
by 64 3 by 3 filters rectified linear
units max point of 2d we flatten out we
get a layer of rectified linear
activation functions dropped out at 50
percent and finally dense layer of soft
max soft max for the 10 classes again
there's a summary of parameters that's
how we drive the parameters and the cool
part about this one one of the things ok
so one of the things that the neural
information processing system people I
can hit people with 10 myths conference
one of the things they noticed you know
people try to pay attention everybody
tries to pay attention everybody else's
work right the gradient boosting people
versus and neural nets people the neural
nets people gone on to the idea of
random subspace projection right like
random forests like keys drop out their
idea of using distortions I haven't seen
make it into other tools like gradient
boosting for example but so here I just
highlighted lines 18 through 21 this is
a this but this data generator specifies
is how to manipulate the data how to
distort the data to get additional
training examples to try to make us just
let more robust so we can shift along
the horizontal axis we can shift along
the vertical axis you know so your
picture right your your picture of your
airplane moves up or down or sideways
that kind of thing
you can do a horizontal flip you could
do a vertical flip it might not make
sense anymore right like why would you
have an upside-down picture of plane of
course you could try to feed an upside
down picture just to see if your image
recognition image recognition engine
still recognizes it might get some
interesting results there so the cool
one of the cool tricks here is he's
using a data generator to help make the
model source a slightly lower bust after
38 pox which is like I'm going to say
2/3 of 40 seconds per epochs per epoch
times 30 about 20 minutes after 20
minutes we're getting like 75 percent
accuracy I think state of the art on
safar is probably 90 95 96 something
like this one of the things you could do
you can use pre train models so one of
the models that comes with Karis is
something called a VG 16 model Oxford
visual geometry group 16 their network
built for image net
[Music]
imagenet has over a million pictures
okay it's one okay so I think by 98
convolutional neural networks were kind
of well-established but they didn't get
become really super popular until the
2010s when they were used for this image
net large-scale visual recognition
challenge competition and they made a
significant decrease in the error
alright so Oxford use this image net
which is over a million images takes a
lot of process especially for sixteen
layer Network but they give you the pre
trained features the image net data
looks like this if our data in fact in
France wash always booked the deep
learning with Python one of the things
he goes over is he takes a kegel
competition data CARICOM it's like data
science competitions right and they did
some image recognition challenge where
you're supposed to distinguish something
from something else we want to say dogs
and Catholic I don't remember but you're
only given a few thousand images oh but
those image net people have over a
million images right so like the kinds
of things to recognize the mm and that
data contains dogs and cats okay so they
use this pre train data just to output
those features remember we looked at
first look at the multi-layer perceptron
and we turned the non linearly separable
data into a smiley face that we could
literally separate the data that was
based on features derived from that
hidden layer all right so we're using
this pre-trained network to generate
features based on convolution so it
doesn't have to have the same size image
you're just rolling this convolution
over convolution filter over your images
it's the convolution filters that make
the big deal to tell you what are
distinctive features right and then let
the following layers that you build
custom I'll choose which features are
relevant for distinguishing cats from
dogs for example which are not
all right um so that's convolutional
neural networks all right text
classification ah
Reuters multi-layer perceptron I am just
going to tell you what that one does
Reuters is a news data set this has a
few thousand observations and
essentially what the multi-layer
perceptron here does is we take the
thousand most frequent words and we say
let's say document one has word zero
word two and word six so all the rest of
these are zeros okay so an observation
then is represented by this vector of
ones and zeros where it's a 1 if we saw
this word in the document although I 0
you can throw that throw that through a
multi-layer perceptron and see what it
does in text and this this notebook
actually covers the text processing and
I tried to spit out things so I modified
the little examples a little spit out
things so you could see the ones and
zeros you can see the words that were
used in the original text that kind of
thing all right ah
the next one is glove these are global
vectors this is what newsgroups data
newsgroups comes from the twenty
newsgroup data comes from unix-like
email just old old style email
distribution list where ret cocky rec
dot sports hockey was one of the
interest groups think of it like reddit
but email right all right uh so global
vectors represent some kind of embedding
a representation of of words so here
there's two too big names and word
embeddings it is word to Veck and glove
or a global vector and variants word to
bec embeddings essentially we're taking
the representation from some hidden
layer of the
in this case a skip Graham architecture
Network the Google people folks at
Google took News data and a lot of news
data and build models where they said
the input is a word grab a word and we
grab another word from the context
within a few words of that word and the
ansel is was this word does this word
appear in the context of does this word
appear in the context of this work yes
or no so for a sentence we can grab all
the other you know based on the size of
the window we're using for skip Graham's
we can say alright let's grab the all
boards within two words of the current
word those are positive class examples
those are next to each other and then we
can grab random words from the rest of
the corpus and saying nope not this not
this not this and the idea is that we're
trying to build a representation for
those words and they had some some
others so there's some interesting blog
posts where they say we can take the
king and Betty and subtract the woman
embedding excuse me ha ha ha
man and Betty so we have a vector a
vector for example of 300 features from
here in this embedding layer there
represent King another vector of it
features a represent man if we subtract
demand values from the King values the
closest vector that we see is clean
that's kind of interesting the novel
trick but so we're looking for a
representation of the word and then so
for glove glove is the same kind of
thing except they've used matrix
factorization ok
and so we here with matrix factorization
we have a co-occurrence matrix of the
word and the context words and then we
sort of like alternating least squares
right where for the Netflix prize where
we take and we say all you know what
we've got some latent word features and
some latent context features and this
vector times this vector will give you
the co-occurrence value here right so
the first first latent vector for words
and the first latent column for the
context this multiplied by this the dot
product of these two gives you the
co-occurrence that's what we're trying
to predict so we can use this
alternating least squares paradigm with
gradient descent something that scales
to build embeddings which one is better
I've heard people go out on a limb and
say oh love love is more accurate
well this molecular form what it depends
your mileage may vary right you should
try it out for your application to see
so newsgroups this notebook 11 takes the
glove representation loads it up into a
Karass layer so that you can predict the
word embeddings for any given word index
right says this this is turned into word
frequencies 17 so word frequency 17
selects the embedding layer 17 note that
representation and then it deeds it to a
convolutional neural network so the same
way you ran a two dimensional filter
against the a against a image you can
run a one dimensional vector against a
email okay and the question there is did
you see it did you see it did you see it
same question right do you see this
pattern you're trying to learn this
pattern through back propagation
and then you can feed that to a dense
layer and feed that out to a softmax
layer I think this one has 46 class or
skewed answering the Reuters news rupes
has 20 or is 46 classes so for example
earning a story about earnings would be
an example of Reuters news article the
news groups has 20 rec sports hockey is
an example in the notebook as it has an
example of somebody talking about Wayne
Gretzky from the late 90s all right so
our last little bit is about recurrent
neural networks with long short-term
memory so a simple recurrent neural
network example this is the picture
people draw these are the inputs they
could be for example characters I'm just
going to give you my interpretation of
this wild email blog post an example of
an interpretation of Lawton Mel Blanc us
we have hidden weights for the inputs we
have hidden weights for the previous
outputs for the first there is no there
is no previous input for the first let's
say we're doing sentiment classification
on internet movie database reviews okay
will I know if the positive review or
negative review to keep track do people
like this movie or not so our sequence
we start off with the first word in the
review so the the previous input doesn't
exist for the first one obviously but as
we go we have a dependency over time
between words right so whether we see
positive were positive words might
depend on what we saw previously you
could use this in this particular
example for the Walden mell book where
it has multiple outputs one preached
position you might use this for
autocomplete right somebody has typed it
type this stuff what do we think is most
likely to be next right for autocomplete
purposes
it's like the feed-forward Network
except we're taking input from the
previous time step there long short-term
memory for a simple recurrent neural
network this defines the output layer
where in the blog F was the hyperbolic
tangent and G is the softmax function in
the case of Internet Movie Database 'as
we don't need these other outputs we
only need the last output that says when
we get to the end of the route is this a
positive or negative negative sentiment
all right so this is these are the
equations driving the outputs for
recurrent neural network the problem is
there's two two types of problems
exploiting gradients values get really
large being propagated okay way to take
care of that is clipping and there is
vanishing gradient values get really
really small what these folks from
twenty years ago came up with this is
the same now same node that we saw
earlier where it has these two weight
matrices notice they're in two weight
matrices eight weight matrices the idea
is that we use these gates input for
getting and output gates input gate here
for getting gate this is we added this
new cell state this forgetting gate says
these weights say should we remember
this information from before the input
gate says to what extent should we pay
attention to with what's taking place
now when we see now and this output gate
says what is actually going to be the
output of this cell so the cell state is
just going from cell to cell and this H
actually goes to some output like
gesundheit
we're like a sigmoid where that we asks
the question is this a positive or a
negative sentiment review
and that is the big picture of long
short-term memory cells they have
examples here Internet Movie Database
example
hooha all right here we're setting up
again the sequential network but we're
adding this LS TM layer okay so we add
nellis TM layer we get point eighty 138
for accuracy on this data set like 0.88
is the tops or was the tops when I was
published by Stanford earlier if we use
two layers we say one forward layer and
then side-by-side we say one backward
layer propagating backward from the end
to the beginning
bi-directional STM we get 85% accuracy
so we're doing better here this is
classic overfitting actually just so you
see epochs as the epochs go up our
accuracy our training data is going up
but our addressing our test data is
going down that is the hallmark of
overfitting
but overall performance went up by using
the bi-directional STM versus the Union
directional OS TM and then this led us
one essentially all we're doing
we're using embeddings with the global
average coin so all the words that we
see we just average them and feed that
to a date dense sigmoid activation layer
with this adaptive moments it's a
different type you know like there's art
there's Scott the great centers rmsprop
root-mean-square propagation there's
also adaptive moments it uses both
rmsprop and a momentum term to avoid the
local minima we use these together it's
a little bit simpler it gets better
that is kind of kind of round
state-of-the-art performance for that
that data set all right there's like
twenty five thousand reviews in training
twenty five thousand reviews and tests
so what kinds of things did we go over a
[Music]
brief intro to deep learning and see mtk
setting up and adhere VM with the GPU
and installing GPU driver scene GK and
caris
and we looked at a bunch of examples
including both feed-forward recurrent
neural networks including scads just
greedy since back propagation
multi-layer perceptron with CNC K and
this logistic regression multi-layer
perceptron with dropout and RMS
propagation for the learning also
convolutional neural networks for both M
minused and C for 10 and then we talked
about MLPs and CN NS for text
classification and we look briefly at
LST m and fast text for Internet Movie
Database reviews there are some CK
references along with a pointer to the
stack over full help page other stuff to
check out baby
you kept alive VA in the eye because
it's somebody's artificial intelligence
baby it's a kind of cool example of
questioning answering reading reading
comprehension there is a speech
recognition example and that comes with
CNC K here with the an for database from
Carnegie Mellon and for kaggle
competitions I would encourage you to
definitely participate and use ensemble
in of different models right use a
shallow deep shallow wide model add to
the ensemble a
beat narrow model that kind of thing to
get some diversity to help boost your
finish top of the leaderboard and that's
it